the colorful world of sunset city is one
of glitz glamour and horrible energy
drink infused monsters
it's the perfect backdrop for sunset
overdrive which is steeped in parody and
irreverent humor if you saw our previous
video on sunset overdrive then you
already know this game began its life as
a mishmash of ideas and inspirations
including everything from Halloween
masks to Popeye cartoons there was a lot
more that went into creating the
signature style of this upcoming
open-world action game join us as we
dive deep into the origins of sunset
overdrive and take a closer look at the
creative process and insomniac games
when we first started doing something
overdrive it was a very different game
it was very serious it was very we were
kind of obsessed with the end times and
zombie movies and novels you know like
if we had gone that or she would have
been in somewhere in the vicinity of
Daisy you're totally hold it but there
was also the fact that we finished
resistance three we both worked on
resistance 3 for many years the
resistance franchise for many years and
we were kind of like we don't want to do
that again we don't want to be stuck in
the gloom in the doom we really should
go back to what makes insomniac great
early on we were influenced by a lot of
things I mean the Gorillaz video yeah we
well we were in the in the sort of the
distill did a Z direction we surround
the time guerrillas on melancholy Hill
video came out and it went around the
studio it's just like they wouldn't this
would be a cool game to make like
something it look like this and and for
that sent up within us off in a whole
different direction style stylistically
the basis went from you know survive and
really kind of that gritty feel to what
about all the fun parts what about Will
Smith's hitting golf balls off of
aircraft carriers and and Charlton
Heston driving giant boats down man the
streets of LA for a while we had the WWI
D what would he do you know if Iggy
Papas was in the end times like yeah he
probably won't survive three days but
it's - you would imagine it would be
this glorious three days when I can just
reverse I think we tried everything
played everything I mean weather like
it's a Tony Hawk Mirror's Edge jet set
radio I mean a lot of people like for
the big jets that radios but I think
it's just it's
constant iteration like you actually
need to tell people like this is what
you're all you're doing this week is
just try something different like okay
what if you just attach to traversal
automatically like we tried that you
know what if you you know couldn't shoot
from traversal like you just use it for
that like he's just constantly trying
different things and having you that the
korea director try it out or other
people in the building or even people
outside the building trying it and just
constantly getting feedback we have this
that's one thing that we did a bunch of
times which was a song mission of people
would you know listen to the song and
other get inspired by the lyrics or
about the you know the style of the song
style the music the beat whatever and
then they design a mission around that
and there's some really creative ideas
that came out of that and then helped us
you know to kind of define the tone
because you know there would be some
missions that they would be like i
really like this but the tone kind of
feels a little off and i don't know for
some reason we had a lot of missions
that were they were based around getting
dates in the end times maybe that says
something more about the team than it
does about us and we've been in business
for 20 years we've been making games for
two decades now and during that time
we've really discovered what it is that
we love to make and i think a lot of
people he'd come to insomniac because in
general we make games that are stylized
now we've made games that are realistic
like resistance and previous games but i
think where most folks hearts lie here
at insomniac is in creating a sense of
irreverence in creating games that have
they don't take themselves completely
seriously that are visually different
and sunset overdrive really plays to
that desire of all of ours to just do
something that isn't the same
slowly but surely all these different
game pieces are coming together to form
one cohesive whole individually bouncing
on cars and grinding on handrails and
firing off explosive teddy bears all
sound fun enough but until you bring
them all together you can never be sure
if what you have is a good video game or
just a bunch of goofy ideas for the team
and insomniac these moments come in
different forms and at different times
but each one is an exciting moment of
you can look forward to getting your
hands on sunset overdrive later this
year exclusively for Xbox one